- Man, I'm not in any of these highlights.
It's like nobody appreciates defense and rebounding anymore.
- [Modern announcer:] Welcome offensive superstar,
2022 Wardell Stephen Curry!
Oh! It's…Draymond.
I mean...yeah!
Welcome to the arena outside of space and time,
where we have, uh,
Draymond Green!
[Crowd cheering]
- Finally getting some respect.
- [Old-school announcer:] Who should we get? Oh!
Versus two-time Defensive Player of the Year,
1998 Dennis "The Worm" Rodman!
- Damn, Phil, you ain't gotta be sendin' portals
to drag me to practice and shit.
- Rodman?! How's your dictator friend?
- Oh, Mike? He good.
- [Modern announcer:] A one-on-one matchup between
two defense-oriented players.
I'm low-key feelin' this.
- [Old-school announcer:] Game's to 11, win by two.
[Crowd booing]
- [Fan 1:] Where are the points?!
- [Fan 2:] What is this, soccer?!
- [Old-school announcer:] OK, change of plans.
Game's now to three, straight up.
- [Modern announcer:] Rodman shoots...oh!
- Let me show you how the Dubs do it.
- [Modern announcer:] That imaginary backpack
gets heavier every year.
- Click. Boom. Rebound.
Shoot.
Score.
Aight, I'm gonna need some me time.
[Club music and horns honking]
- [Old-school announcer:] Well, looks like Rodman's left the arena
for Portal Vegas.
[Crickets]
[Shoes squeaking]
- [Green:] Don't leave me open.
- [Modern announcer:] And Draymond misses an uncontested two.
What's this?
[Crowd cheering]
- Aight, let's get on with this bullshit.
I think I married Saturn in Portal Vegas.
Ooh! My little worm.
- [Modern announcer:] Draymond reaching into his sack of tricks.
- [Old-school announcer:] A Rodman hair change!
Good luck, Draymond.
- [Fan:] This is gettin' good!
- You got this. I ain't about to lose to no bum
whose sorry-ass team only went 72-10!
- Man, you runnin' your mouth like Barkley.
- Shit, I do it way better than Barkley.
- [Modern announcer:] Rodman shoots.
Rims out. Who will get the rebound?
One, two, three, four, five tips to secure it!
- [Old-school announcer:] And Rodman wins, three to two!
- [Rodman laughing]
- [Fans:] Whoa, crushed it! No cap!
A low-scoring affair and the fans don't even seem pissed.
[Crowd chanting "defense"]
- [Rodman:] Hey, I need a light.
- [Old-school announcer:] This is not how you should
treat the media!
- [Fan:] I love defense, woo!
- Ah, I finally found fans who appreciate my
defensive-minded approach to the game.
That's enough for me.
- [Warriors fan:] Hey everyone! Steph is shootin' threes from the parking lot!
- Portal, take me back!